R
HYPOCRITES THAT THEY ARE.
>> Sean: CONGRESSWOMAN,
THANK YOU, CONGRESSMAN BANKS,
THANK YOU, JOINING US NOW,
AUTHOR OF "SAVING NINE," UTAH
SENATOR MIKE LEE.
SENATOR, YOU ARE ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE I KNOW THAT REALLY CARES
ABOUT OUR CONSTITUTION AND I
GIVE YOU A LOT OF CREDIT.
WE DID A REVEAL, IT WAS REVEALED
DURING THESE HEARINGS THAT
JAMIE RASKIN HAS ANOTHER MOTIVE
IN ALL OF THIS.
HE WANTS TO GET RID OF THAT
OUTDATED RELIC CALLED THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION, THAT CALLS
FOR ELECTORS TO END UP PICKING
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME BECAUSE
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT LIZ
CHENEY'S FATHER NEVER WOULD HAVE
BEEN ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE --
>> THAT'S RIGHT -- YEAH, HE
WANTS TO ELIMINATE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, WHICH IS
ABOUT AS FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT AS IT
COMES.
THERE IS NO WAY AROUND THIS.
LOOK, THE U.S. CONSTITUTION HAS
FOSTERED THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
GREATEST CIVILIZATION THE WORLD
HAS EVER KNOWN.
FOR REASONS THAT ESCAPE, STYLED,
AND DISMAY ME, THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS TO
THROW IT UNDER THE BUS, THROW IT
UNDER THE BUS WITH STATEMENTS
LIKE THAT HE IS AMAZING.
THEY WANT TO THROW IT UNDER THE
BUS BY DENIGRATING THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND BY PACKING THE
COURT SO THEY CAN TURN IT INTO A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL.
AND SEAN, THE THING IS, WITHOUT
THE SUPREME COURT BEING AN
INDEPENDENT ARBITER OF WHAT THE
LAW IS, THERE IS NO
CONSTITUTION.
THEY WANT TO PACK IT SO THEY CAN
DESTROY THE COURT AND IN SO
DOING DESTROY THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS WHY I WROTE
"SAVING NINE," "SAVING NINE"
TELLS THE STORY OF THE LAST TIME
THIS HAPPENED AND THE FACT WE
ARE STILL PAYING THE PRICE FOR
IT.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU LOOK AT FOR
EXAMPLE ABOLISHING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE OR PACKING THE
COURTS OR STATEHOOD FOR D.C. OR
GETTING RID OF THE FILIBUSTER,
ALL OF THESE ITEMS THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BROUGHT UP, AND YOUR BOOK
REALLY DOES HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SUPREME COURT,
WHEN THEY DO THIS, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO THINGS
THAT THEY CAN NEVER GET DONE AT
THE BALLOT BOX OR NEVER GET DONE
IN CONGRESS, LEGISLATIVELY, AND
THEY WANT THE COURTS TO DO THEIR
JOB FOR THEM AND LEGISLATE FROM
THE BENCH.
THAT IS NOT PARTICULARLY GOOD
FOR OUR COUNTRY, IS IT?
>> NO, IT IS TERRIBLE FOR OUR
COUNTRY, AND IT DOES NOT WORK
OUT WELL FOR ANYONE, BUT
SOMETIMES FOR THEM IT WORKS OUT
IN THE SHORT TERM, BUT IN THE
LONG TERM IT HURTS EVERYONE,
INCLUDING AND ESPECIALLY THEM.
BUT IF THEY ATTEMPT THIS AGAIN,
IF THEY TRY TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT AGAIN, UNLIKE
1937 -- I TELL THE STORY IN
"SAVING NINE" OF HOW
FRANKLIN D. ROOSEVELT, SORT OF A
HERO, A ROLE MODEL, AN IDOL, IF
YOU WILL, TO JOE BIDEN, HE TRIED
TO DO THIS BACK IN 1937.
IT FAILED IN PART BECAUSE THERE
WERE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS THAT
WERE WILLING TO STAND UP TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT AT THE
TIME.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT TODAY.
NOR DO WE HAVE THE BUFFER THAT
WE HAD BACK IN 1937.
BUT AS I EXPLAINED IN
"SAVING NINE," BACK IN 1937,
EVEN THOUGH IT FAILED
LEGISLATIVELY, IT COURSED THE
SUPREME COURT TO SWITCH ITS VIEW
OF A PARTICULAR PROVISION OF THE
CONSTITUTION, AND THAT
REINTERPRETATION WITH A DE FACTO
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
THAT HAS CAUSED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT TO BECOME TOO
BIG, TOO EXPENSIVE, AND TO
FAR-REACHING, WE ARE PAYING
FOR IT EVER SINCE THEN.
ALL THESE EFFORTS TO DENIGRATE
THE CONSTITUTION AND OUR SYSTEM,
YOU CAN DRAW -- THE STATEMENTS
OF JAMIE RASKIN, THE EFFORTS TO
PROTEST OUTSIDE OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES HOMES, EFFORTS TO
ASSASSINATE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES, AND THE REFUSAL OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO CONDEMN GOING TO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HOMES TO
PROTEST IN FRONT OF, HARASS
THEM, TRY TO GET THEM TO CHANGE
THE RULING IN A CASE.
THAT IS WRONG, AND IT IS COUNTER
TO EVERYTHING WE BELIEVE IN
ABOUT CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, IT IS
AMAZING TO ME THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE GAVE THEIR TACIT
APPROVAL AND ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGED, IN THE CASE OF
JEN PSAKI, THE DOXXINGS OF THESE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HOMES.
WE KNOW THE TAPE OF SCHUMER, YOU
KNOW, YOU BETTER LISTEN TO ME,
GORSUCH, YOU BETTER LISTEN TO
ME, KAVANAUGH, YOU WON'T KNOW
WHAT HIT YOU.
THAT SOUNDED LIKE A THREAT TO
ME.
IF I MADE A THREAT TO A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, WOULD I
BE COMMITTING A CRIME?
>> YES.
YES, YOU WOULD.
AND YOU WOULD ESPECIALLY BE
COMMITTING A CRIME IF YOU WERE
GOING TO THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES HOMES TO PROTEST IN
FRONT OF THEM, AND IF YOU ARE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHO ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO DO THAT,
AND THROUGH YOUR PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI, IF YOU SAID
YES, I SUPPORT THIS, YOU WOULD
BE ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING THAT.
WE KNOW HE ENCOURAGES IT.
WE KNOW THEREFORE THAT HE IS
TRYING TO PACK THE COURT.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP THEM NOW AND
THAT IS WHY I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO READ "SAVING NINE" TO GIVE
THEM THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
CONFRONT THIS.
WE NEED AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE TO READ IT SO THEY ARE
READY TO RESPOND.
WE NEED THE HELP OF A